now remember when the democrats used to
be all about hope and change i was born
in a little town called hope arkansas it
was a wonderful little small town
where you know it seemed that everybody
knew everybody else do we participate
in a politics of cynicism
or do we participate in a politics of
hope hope in the face of difficulty hope
in the face of uncertainty but now the
democrat party is singing a different
tune always die in a military coup
democracy dies at the ballot box that's
exactly right i actually think there's a
fair chance that we could completely
lose
our constitutional democracy for a
couple of decades
if we keep making if we make bad
decisions oh my god talk about looking
defeated bad decisions is that what bill
clinton just talked about
well we know what a bad decision was
don't we deciding to endorse biden in
the first place
now of all people bill clinton should
have warned his party about the risks of
veering too far to the left after all
a more centrist approach is what gave
bill clinton two terms in the white
house
and by the way it's not just the end of
democracy all together that they're
warning about
some are even predicting a civil war
this is a group that has been
radicalized by the great replacement
myth and many other things and have been
pushing for violence and pushing for
even civil war
let me say this that was one of the most
irresponsible comments i've heard in a
long time and that's a long list
we wholeheartedly reject this dark and
pessimistic view of our country
now what ails america now
is the agenda of the far-left
progressives the fanatics that have
taken the democratic party hostage and
set us on this disastrous path we now
find ourselves on
like we don't have to have six dollar a
gallon gas we don't have to have a
president who is a complete
embarrassment on the world stage
we certainly don't have to have
criminals owning our streets
we know we don't have to have an open
border
back in 2019 pre-pandemic we had none of
those things
and we had low unemployment rising wages
higher optimism no inflation
you know what we had
we had peace and prosperity
and we can have it again
and even during covet i was thinking
about this trump did operation warp
speed he urged america to get back to
work get back to school get back to
business
had we done just that moving through the
bidet administration and kept going with
our energy independence controlled our
streets our borders
my god we'd be in a very strong position
right now vis-a-vis china and russia and
the other adversaries
but unfortunately for us
and i warned about this in the campaign
biden is too weak to stand up to the
fanatics on the far left
and look at what they've done already
how much harm they've done to urban
america
and now much of that harm is starting to
spread coast to coast because of the
economic pain before us
now even the new york times that is
admitting this today
saying this is going to hurt
of course trump and many of us predicted
most everything that's unfolding right
now
right down to the gas prices and a
collapse in the stock market
we were right sadly
and they with their rosy predictions
about how wonderful and dignified and
elated and harmonious everything would
be under biden they were wrong
the truth is they set out from day one
to lower our standard of living
to diminish our freedoms and to
radically alter the american landscape
and to some extent they've
accomplished a lot of that
now they did this because
they never much had a lot of faith in
america in the first place
and frankly they just don't like the
american people very much either
they hate our history they hate our
founding our traditions our patriotism
even our own borders
to them it's not really the land of the
free and the home of the brave it's the
land that was stolen and the home of the
races
and because americans are on the verge
of throwing them out of office
they suddenly want to tell us democracy
no longer works or it's in jeopardy
no let me tell you how it goes when
democrats lose huge in november and then
in 2024
we will once again see the genius of the
founders at play
the people will have had their say and
they'll have rejected the failed
policies and foolish corrupt politicians
who enacted them and after that
it's restoration time and that's the
angle hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else